This is Jocko podcast number one 77 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
A few days later when I walked downstairs to go workout,
I saw uncle Jake's bag packed up sitting by the door.
That's when it hit me.
The summer was almost over and uncle Jake was leaving again.
Yeah,
I went out to the garage to work out and uncle Jake was already there,
last workout with me for the summer.
He said,
with a smile,
I can't believe it's over already.
Summer always goes by so fast.
I told him,
yes it does.
Uncle Jake said quietly,
and life does the same thing.
I wasn't sure what Uncle Jake meant by that,
so I asked what you'll see,
mark.
He said,
life goes by quickly,
like a summer day.
It never seems that way when you're young,
but when you get a little older you'll see life goes by fast,
so don't waste any time you don't get a second chance.
Uncle Jake stood for a minute looking at me with a serious face and he gave me a
little smile and said,
speaking of wasting time,
let's stop wasting time and get this workout done.
He jumped up on the pullup bar,
grabbed hold and started knocking them out
and that
is a little excerpt from the last chapter.
You need new book,
the latest edition in the series where the warrior could kid book three.
The subtitle of book is where there is a will,
and
I wrote that part of the book because I wanted to let kids know as early as
possible that that is the truth.
That life goes by like a summer day
and that life is short.
And if you remember when you were a kid and summer you get out of school for the
summer and it seems like you have all the time in the world,
it seems like summer vacation,
it's going to last for ever
and then all of a sudden it's blurred and you look up and as soon as summer
vacation has started,
all of a sudden it's over.
That's what I remember about summers.
And that's the truth.
And that's what life is like
about.
Yeah.
A year and a half ago,
September 29th,
2017 and September 29th St Michael's Day,
that's the day that Mikey monster was killed in Ramadi in 2006 so on September
29th,
2017 I woke up and I was thinking about that.
I was thinking about Mikey and
later that day,
I think I was actually heading up to Rosecrance national cemetery where Mike,
he is buried and all was going to go and visit Mikey's grave.
And while I was on my way up there,
I got a call and I found out that one of my mentors,
one of the guys that raised me in the seal teams,
a guy named master chief Mike Faculty,
he had died.
Yeah.
And he had been in a pretty hardcore battle with lung cancer even though he was
a nonsmoker,
even though he's a traff,
we'd even though he worked out all the time,
he got this form of lung cancer and originally the doctors told him he was going
to live for six months,
but that was in I think 2012 he had retired in 2001
and I sit there thinking about faculty and actually Btf Tony talked about him,
called him fat when he was on the podcast because we all called him Faq.
But I remembered,
yeah,
just a bunch of different things about fac.
And one of the things that I remembered was I had come back from my third
deployment,
so this is in the nineties back in the day.
And I had done my third deployment and I had been moved into the training
department at seal team one.
So instead of doing a workup and going on deployment,
the way the teams used to be set up,
you would,
you would go into training cell and the team trained itself,
the training department at seal team one train to the platoons at seal team one
later it became that we had a big centralized training command.
That's what I ran before I got out before I retired.
I ran that,
the trade at on the west coast.
But it used to be each team had their own training cell and that's how you would
train platoons to get ready for their deployments.
Okay.
And of course nobody really wanted to be in training cell because it meant you
couldn't go on deployment and that's why you joined the seal teams is to go on
deployment.
And for whatever reason we'd in a bunch of us from my platoon that I'd gone
through buds with a bunch of guys,
we don't all done three platoons and they kinda,
we all kinda got thrown into training cell at the same time and we'd been in
there for a couple days.
I mean maybe less than a week,
we'd come back from deployment,
we get put into training cell and I kind of forget what happened,
but a couple of guys that were getting ready to deploy got hurt.
In fact,
it might've been guys had gotten hurt as soon as they got over there and maybe
they didn't go on deployment.
The guys that went and replaced us,
all of a sudden they needed a couple guys and at corridors in the morning,
that's when
at seal team one,
they used to have quarters in the morning where you all stand up and line up,
sort of like your typical military formation.
Everyone would kind of line up and buy platoon in.
The platoons would all report in those old school team one deal right there.
And then if there was any important announcements to make than the announcements
would get made and then everyone would go about their day.
Well,
the announcement that got made that morning was,
hey,
we need two guys to go on deployment.
Is there anyone here that feels like going on deployment or can go on
deployment?
And of course it's a big deal,
right,
to just pick up and go and leave for six months.
And it was actually my roommate at the time who had been my roommate who I went
through buds with and who I did three platoons with.
I went through seal tactical training with,
with them and we were actually roommates that entire time.
So we were,
we were tight.
You'd my brother and when they asked this question of,
Hey,
is there anybody here that can go on deployment like tomorrow or the next day?
And basically out of the whole team,
it was him and me.
We raised our hands,
said,
yeah,
hey,
we'll go.
Because at that time,
you know,
we were just single team guys.
We didn't have anything else.
We literally had nothing else.
You could put our whole world into two crews boxes and we could ship anywhere in
the world.
We didn't care.
We had no attachments.
We had didn't care about anything.
So of course we raised our hands
and as soon as our hands went up,
master chief faculty gave us a glare because he was the guy that was in charge
of training cell.
So he gave us a glare and quarters ended and he goes,
he said,
hey,
what you guys come up to Gerson talk to me real quick.
And I was thinking,
okay,
we must have done something wrong.
And you sometimes you didn't know what you did wrong.
But I,
me and my buddy,
we figured we'd done something wrong.
So we went up there and actually actually now to think about it when he brought
us into the chief's mess and we were like he fours or fives at the time and so
gold getting pulled into the chief chiefs mess.
I'd never been in there before.
And I was like scared thinking,
well what did I thought I did something wrong.
I thought that I left a trail of some crime,
I committed and now we're getting busted and we get up there and basically he
reamed us out and he says,
listen,
you guys need to be in training.
So,
and he was making great points I didn't recognize at the time.
And he's like,
look,
if you want to be professionals,
if this is where you're going to learn a lot,
we need good guys to be teaching the rest of the platoons.
That's why you're in here.
You're not going on deployment.
Shut up and I'm pulling your names out of the hat and they'll find two other
people that can go,
we'll send some new guys over there.
Doesn't matter.
So that's what it was.
That was this little story.
And it was,
it was funny because you know,
we were,
it was just funny from multiple reasons when I thought back about it,
just the fact that you're in a point in your life,
I think I was probably like 23 or 24 years old.
And just,
just think about right now,
if someone says,
Hey,
can you just leave for six months tomorrow?
I mean there's not too many people that can just pull up and do that.
So there's that.
There's the fact that,
you know,
faculty was bringing us into the chief's mess and we were all nervous about
that.
And then the fact that,
you know,
faculty,
what he was actually doing was trying to look out for us and try to look out for
our careers and trying to look out for the seal team.
He was trying to do the right thing and it was,
was one of those,
one of those little stories and there's just all these little stories like that
that,
that make up that whole era of my life,
that whole time as a young enlisted guy on seal team on,
it's this whole bunch of memories.
And when he died I got this feeling that those memories,
those those days are over rector going
because at least partially because when fac was around a part of those memories
are facts,
memories.
Like only he could tell us what he was thinking at that time and when he dies,
when he died,
then they didn't.
Those memories are gone.
And Ricky,
I can't ask him about them.
I can't go and have a beer with them and talk about that time.
And hear his side of it.
Like,
no,
they're,
they're not here,
they're gone.
And
right as I was,
you know,
again,
going up to see Mikey Monsoor at Rosecrance and continue to think about that and
thinking about the memories that Mikey had and
how those are going.
Okay.
But I didn't have too much time to dig into those thoughts because the next
morning,
September 30th,
2017 that's when I got word that the Delta platoon commander,
my brother Seth stone had died as well.
And
all kinds of memories
died with him.
I mean,
I got my half of them,
but it's half,
it's incomplete conversations and jokes and guitar jams.
And then on top of those I get little,
yeah,
like Seth was incredibly smart and he'd give me little ideas,
little FOBTs,
but only the beginning of them because there's millions of things to talk about
and you think you've got your whole life to,
to consider those things,
but you don't.
And I get that we can try and talk about them or we can try and write them down
and we can do everything in our power to try and hang on to those things.
No,
but the fact of the matter is you,
you can't,
you can't preserve them in their true form.
It's just gone.
And as I
thought about that and as I continue to think about that and try and figure out
what can we do?
Yeah.
If we can't
preserve these memories
then what can we do
mean?
I think the best thing that we can do is try and make more.
Yeah.
Try and make more,
make more memories.
So
to keep in mind what uncle Jake said.
Yeah.
Wife goes by like a summer day.
So you better take advantage of it.
Right?
When your best make yourself
some memories along the way.
And with that,
the echo.
Yes.
It's been a little while since we
did some Q.
And.
A.
Yes sir.
What do you got?
We got some questions from the inner webs.
All right,
we'll go into it.
First question,
what do you do when the boss always says we can't,
but does it offer logical and reasonable alternatives to make positive forward
changes?
Should one just do what they think is best and not listened to the boss?
Uh,
okay.
First of all,
what we want to do is we want to support the boss.
We want to build a relationship with the boss.
What's the best way to support the boss?
Which quote?
The way to build relationship is to be a performer.
Be a performer inside the box,
right?
That the bosses said,
you can't do this.
You can't do that.
Cool.
We're going to do the best we can in side the box.
And once you do that,
once you,
once you actually,
once you actually are a performer,
then you have leverage.
Then you can actually talk about a different way of doing things.
You can bring up a legitimate idea to the boss and they may well they have a
better chance of listening to you.
So that's what you gotta do.
You gotta play the game a little bit.
You gotta,
you gotta become a performer.
You've got to do what it is,
the way they want it done to the best of your ability,
be successful with it.
And then once you built up some clout and some relationship and maybe a little
political capital,
then you can present a new idea and when you present the new idea,
have the facts lined up,
don't go in there half cocked and present your idea and hopefully gets cleared.
Now that's one,
that's section A.
Section B is do you got to make things happen?
Sometimes you,
and depending on how,
like it's that whole thing of it's better to beg forgiveness than ask for
permission.
That's a really,
that's a,
it's,
it's a,
it's a tool.
It's definitely a tool.
If you abuse it,
if you're going to get crushed,
if it's one of those things where the boss has told you not to do something and
you decide,
well I'm going to do it anyways and I'll just beg for forgiveness,
they actually told you not to do it.
That's not where you're supposed to use that tool.
Yeah,
that's just,
that's just unsat onset.
If it's something where,
well I kind of suspect that the boss might not want it this way,
but you know what,
chances are it's going to go in my direction and chances are it's going to be
beneficial and chances are the boss might not even found out.
And if the boss does find out this isn't something that they've ever declared
hostile,
right.
So you'll be okay in that situation too to beg for forgiveness but don't abuse
that tool.
And in which you do is you start if when you're inside the,
hey,
I'm going to beg for forgiveness,
then you can start actually doing something in developing a standard operating
procedure that makes sense.
And then once you get it solidified,
you'd go to the Boston say,
Hey boss,
we've been doing this a different way.
I want to let you know I want to show you what we've been doing cause we,
you know,
Boston,
we never really had a specific way of getting this done.
And I know some other people did it like this and some people did it like that.
We came up with a methodology,
actually wrote the whole thing out for you so you can see exactly what we're
doing.
Boom was going to say no to that.
Plus it's been successful 80 times.
Boom,
we're good.
So,
so that's what you want to do.
That's pretty,
pretty straight forward.
Don't,
don't just straight disobeyed the boss on less.
The bosses are telling you to do something that's gonna get someone killed or
illegal or whatever.
But
if they're just have a different idea or something,
just go with it,
execute it,
become a good performer.
And then once you have that relationship built,
you'll have all kinds of influence over your boss always had crazy influence
over my bosses.
Yeah.
I don't want to sound,
I want to say in an arrogant way.
It wasn't like I was manipulating my bosses,
but my boss is like,
I was honest with my bosses and they,
I did good work.
And so when I said,
hey boss is,
we sure we should do it this way.
They'd be like,
well what do you think?
And I'd say,
well,
here's what I think,
and then we'd get shit done.
So pretty straightforward.
Pretty straightforward.
Yeah.
That asking for forgiveness thing Dubiski move.
Is that a risky move?
But sometimes it's a great,
great move.
Yeah.
If you kind of like how you said like don't abuse it,
where you know there's levels to it where there's like little things,
32 levels.
So like if you,
if there's one that's like how you said,
like he told you not to do something,
and this goes for like anyone,
like you're eating when you're dealing with like even your friends kind of
thing,
you know,
where if they,
if you know for a fact that they don't want you to do it.
So that's why you'd prefer not to ask for permission because you know they're
going to say no,
but you know,
it's like about,
you shouldn't do that and you know that.
But if it's the kind where it's like,
hmm,
I can see why he'd want to do it,
maybe this way,
or maybe not even necessarily want to do this way because maybe he doesn't see
the benefits that we see right now,
but,
and he's still closed minded.
He's,
you know,
he has that reputation,
so let's,
let's sort of do it.
I you said successfully,
you know,
kind of thing.
So,
and then that's when the other side of the spectrum,
you know,
but some people,
men,
they'll just like take it to level five or whatever and be like,
oh yeah,
they're going to hate this boat.
It's better to ask for forgiveness than permission.
Goosing those two guaranteed.
No and forgiveness at least liking of,
but probably you're going to damage the relationship.
If you do this kind of stuff,
then you're going to get tightened down on.
Yeah.
Right.
Like a step backwards.
Oh yeah man,
it's true.
Don't,
don't let that happen.
Don't let that next question.
I'm the youngest leader in my firm's history.
I try and implement extreme ownership and default aggressiveness in my team.
Being so young,
some of my elders subordinate sometimes dismiss my directors.
How do I lead those people effectively?
Okay.
So I actually hate when I get this question or questions like this because it
means that I screwed up that sort of gains.
I don't like to screw up.
When I see a question like this,
it means that somebody has misinterpreted the message a little bit and they
haven't read the dichotomy of leadership for sure in my opinion.
Because if you read the dichotomy of leadership,
you'll see that extreme ownership and default aggressive are supposed to be
balanced.
And so that's what's going on here.
You got someone that's like,
you know what?
I'm good at to take extreme ownership.
We're doing this my way.
I'm the boss,
I'm a leader and that's just horrible and everyone hates you.
So Bro,
you're young.
They don't hate you because you're young.
They're not mad at you because you're an experienced.
They don't dismiss you because um,
because you
are a decade younger than them.
That's not why it's happening.
It's happening because you are lacking humility.
You haven't built up any relationship with these people.
You haven't built up any leadership capital with them.
You haven't asked them how they think they should do things.
You haven't asked them what they'd been doing for the last 22 years while you
were going to middle school.
Right.
So come in,
be humble.
The best way to gain respect from people in this is what's hard to do it.
This is what's hard to understand.
You want people to respect.
You.
Ask them a question,
listen to what they have to say.
Listen to their opinion.
If they come up with a good plan,
use their plan.
The worst way to gain respect from people is to go in and demand respect from
people is to go in and say,
I'm implementing default.
Chris,
if you've not heard of that,
you've never read extreme ownership,
have you?
I'll tell you what,
that's the way we're doing it here.
I'll get you a copy so you can read up and get on board with my program.
These are all bad,
so I'm not trying to say you sound just like that,
but you might sound something like that and you don't need to be too far off
that,
so appreciate that you're getting after it,
but what you need to get after more is some balance.
Be Humble.
Listen to the team,
listen to what they have to say.
Ask for their input,
follow their input when you can.
That's a little black belt move.
It's a little black belt and it's actually a blue belt move.
But blue belt,
purple belt move like,
Hey,
my team gives me input.
I listened to them.
We actually,
you know,
hey echo,
how do you think we should,
I think we should attack this target from the north.
Okay,
sounds good.
Why don't we roll with that?
That's a blue belt move man.
What's a,
what's a white belt move negative?
No,
the white belt moves like,
hey echo,
we're doing this,
we're talking just target from the south.
I'm,
you've got any questions?
And you're like,
well I think I could from the north might be a little bit better.
That might be what you think,
but that's not what we're doing.
Plus I'm in charge cause I got ownership of this whole thing and um,
I'm default aggressive.
Sort of do what I said.
So don't be that guy,
man,
to try and back off a little bit.
Try and do.
As a leader you should be looking at like what are your primary goals?
If your primary goal is to form a relationship with your team,
with the people in your team.
Yeah.
So get it done.
I remember in Jujitsu one time,
Greg Macintyre,
great country.
Yes.
He,
uh,
he,
he was teaching a move in the move that he was teaching.
He,
uh,
apparently got from me
and so he was teaching this move or whatever.
And uh,
you know,
sitting there,
we're all in.
He was teaching,
he taught,
he had taught a good thought it way better than I could teach.
Yeah.
Way Better.
In fact,
he taught it,
I simply probably could not teach this move.
And he,
uh,
and after he was done,
he was like,
Hey,
echo does is move really good too.
The class equity equity,
you have anything to add to them?
And I was like,
oh no,
I don't,
I don't remember if I did.
I don't think I did,
but just that feeling,
you know what,
he included me in it,
you know?
And then it was so,
you know,
even though he was,
any in his mind,
and I actually thinking back on in my mind like that,
that was kind of my move.
You know,
what move was it?
It was,
it was a card pass move to one always.
Do you
know what you mean by always?
Yeah.
But nonetheless I could just how you say like how you asked their input kind of
thing.
It's like you include them in the thing that just says,
not just asking yet.
It's actually receiving it and implementing it.
That's the,
that's the,
that's the closure of the move man.
Yeah.
That's the closure of the move.
Roy,
talk about like a feeling and granted,
me and Greg are good friends anyway,
but I'm just saying like you can imagine that situation,
how they,
how anyone would feel when you,
especially if you're older than this little young buck,
who does he think he is and he comes to you.
You're like,
Oh hell yeah.
Okay.
This guy knows like,
you know,
we can,
we can do this together.
Really get that feeling.
I would imagine.
Anyway,
that's what you want to do,
Mr youngest leader in your firm's history.
Dan,
congrats on that.
Congrats on you're getting after it.
What got you there may not get you to the next level.
What got you there?
Might've been like being aggressive and making things happen and stepping up.
That's cool.
But if you piss off everyone in your department that's not gonna work out good
for you and they'll start to undermine you,
they'll sabotage you.
So you gotta be careful.
Yeah,
that's rough check.
Okay.
Is there a possibility that everyone in the department and you got put in there
to straighten things out?
That's a different question.
Let me tell you something else.
When you get it,
when people are dismissing what you're saying,
that's a horrible sign.
I'm one of the leadership books that we covered.
The rule was don't give commands that you,
that walk that aren't going to be followed because every time you give a command
that that you know isn't going to be followed,
it's not gonna work out good for you.
It's reinforcing the fact that no one needs to listen to you.
So don't,
don't be giving orders that are being dismissed if somebody doesn't do
something,
you go,
hey man,
I know that I might've come across a little wrong when I was talking to you
about,
you know,
getting this done,
this product part of this task done.
And I see it's still not,
don't is there,
is there some support that you need from me?
Is there some help that you need from me?
Cause this is important that I probably didn't do a good job of explaining why
it's important,
but it is actually connected to this larger project that we're doing over at
headquarters.
This is our part of the task and I don't,
I don't think I explained that very well,
but do you need anything else from me to maybe move this along?
You can't just allow things to be for you to talk to for you to give directions
and they just get blown off.
Like that's not good.
It wouldn't.
I know what I'm not saying,
Oh,
you blow off my order now I'm going to go high order on you.
Right.
That's not what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that makes sense too,
because man,
if I,
if I had a boss who else was primed to dismiss any of his directives and it
happened and it happened successfully,
like all dismissed it and there was really no real repercussions.
Oh,
you better believe I'm picking and choosing what I'm falling.
And by the way,
that's,
he's testing the envelope anyway.
She's testing to see what he can get away with,
but because he sees you're young,
buck rolling in here thinks going to tell me what to do,
watch this.
I can listen to you.
Okay,
cool.
Now if you fly off the handle and go nuts,
you know what?
You'll get them to do it immediately.
Yeah.
And then guess what?
You're going to get undermined.
You're going to get usurped.
You're going to get,
they're going to have the project fail just so they can get rid of you.
They're going to laugh at you.
Yeah,
that's bad.
As the,
as the,
as you're getting walked out by the HR department.
So did you gotta be careful man.
You gotta be careful.
That's what I'm saying.
Balance these things out.
Balance.
Extreme ownership.
Get the book dichotomy of leadership.
That's what it's about.
It's about being balanced.
Cool.
Next question,
Jocko.
What do you do when people treat you like a doormat
and then when you finally put your foot down,
they lose their minds?
I tried to be agreeable,
but there's a limit when I stand my ground,
people act shocked.
Any advice?
Yeah,
so this is actually kind of the same thing,
right?
You'd need to be balanced because what's happened with this dude,
I assume,
is that sitting around getting,
getting like a pushover,
like a doormat.
People are kind of walking all over them.
Then all of a sudden he does the instant one 80 and goes,
puts his foot down,
right foot down and now you think that they're going to do a one 80 you think
that they're going to say,
oh,
sorry,
I didn't mean to,
oh sorry.
Echo.
I didn't,
I didn't know that.
That offended you.
I'm sorry.
No,
when you do that,
they're like,
what's wrong with you?
You just started tripping.
Yeah,
yeah.
You're freaking out over nothing.
So of course when you stand their ground they're going to be shocked,
right?
Which is what you're saying happened.
This is like no surprise at all.
So what you need to do is,
is you gotta draw the line a little bit earlier,
but without going nuts.
And I think I got a good example of how you do this.
Okay.
Let's say you've got a dog and the dog is like kind of mellow and happy and just
doesn't,
just all good.
And then like all of a sudden,
you know,
you're walking by the dog one day and pop,
it bites you on the arm.
Like,
like big time.
Yeah,
big time.
How do you feel about that dog get bad?
I don't like that.
That's bad.
That dog is getting put down.
Yeah,
right?
Yes.
This dog,
let's say a bit.
One of your kids.
Oh yeah.
That,
that dog is getting put down.
Okay.
So that,
that's what this guy's doing all acting all like everything's like nothing
bothering me.
And all of a sudden biting people.
Think about what a dog like a normal dog does.
What a normal dog does is it's,
if it starts getting offended a little bit or starts getting problems,
it's,
it like stands up a little bit,
right?
And then it's gonna it's going to grow.
That's an indicator.
So even a kid,
even a child knows,
I don't know what age,
but pretty young kids know that a Groundling dog is uh,
is is a warning.
What else do dogs do?
Dog show their teeth.
That's another warning.
Like,
hey,
that's another line in the sand
and,
and barking,
right?
Cause you have to bark.
And I mean a dog barks at you in a dog barks you,
it's got your attention.
It's growling at you.
You know what's going to happen next if you keep doing whatever it is you're
doing right.
You didn't get back away from that dog.
Now if you did,
if the bud Doggett all those things to you and then it bitch you,
you,
you'll still be mad at it.
But you at least know that you kind of had it coming,
right?
Right.
Yes sir.
Yes.
So,
so there you go.
That's what this dude needs to do a little bit of.
He needs to learn how to growl a little bit.
How to bark a little bit,
how to show your teeth little how to just stand up posture.
Correct.
Cause there's,
you know,
a dog,
if you know dogs at all,
dogs have a posture and they have a posture.
Their ears are down in their,
their,
their tails down.
When,
when they get fired up,
boom,
ears are up there on alert.
Their back is,
they get the cackles can stand up and everything.
That means like,
okay,
that's,
that's even before growling.
That's happening alert.
So this dude needs to learn how to come to an alert in improve his po increases
posture.
In those moments,
not when it's getting too far,
but like when someone,
when someone gives you a Little Jab,
you know,
you can't bite them.
You've got a little,
give a little growl.
Yeah,
back them off a little bit.
You know?
And again,
this is,
I don't know you,
you know,
so it's hard for me to say.
Some people just have a hard time dealing with when people harass them
because I think the best thing to do when somebody makes fun of me is just to
like,
be like,
yeah,
that's a good one.
You know?
Like,
cause you know,
just like we were talking about before we started this podcast,
if I let you know that whatever you just said to me bothers me,
bro.
I can expect you to just keep getting after that until I snapped.
Right.
So you gotta be careful.
You don't want to be all hypersensitive.
The other thing to remember is,
man,
when people are making fun of you,
it's not like they hate you most of the time.
Yeah.
You know,
it's not that big of a deal.
Like people talk smack to each other,
right.
People talk smack to each other and,
and I guarantee this is this,
is this a good way to think about it?
If someone talks smack to you,
if you if and then you both leave,
let's say it's at work,
you go home.
The other person that was talking smack goes home.
You go home.
You're thinking about it.
That person that was talking smack didn't think about it one millisecond after
we left the office.
He doesn't care.
He's not sitting there thinking about you.
He's not thinking like,
man,
Oh man,
I'm really glad I told you know you had a funny looking eyebrows.
That was awesome.
I can't leave a weird,
his eyebrows are like,
I mean that's like he's not doing that right.
He's not even thinking about it.
He just went home.
He's carried on his life.
Carry on with your life.
Don't get all tied up about what these other people are thinking of you.
It's not that big of a deal.
Don't sit around thinking about it's,
it's a,
it's a perception that we have that the whole world revolves around us and that
people are sitting around thinking about us all the time.
It's like they're not thinking about you all the time.
They don't care.
They're there at home.
There's not too many people that are actually thinking about you all the time,
especially if they're making fun of you.
Like they're,
they're not thinking about that all
the time.
So just relax,
take a wrap off and just,
you know,
try and have a little bit less tension and you know,
and try and learn to growl a little bit or at least protect your space a little
bit.
And I,
these are kind of contrary or contradictory things that I'm saying I want,
I was like,
Hey,
laugh at it.
The other ones I kind of learned to growl a little bit.
I would say first the first method is better.
The first method is like,
Hey,
just laugh it off.
Don't worry about it.
These people aren't thinking about you.
They don't care that probably it's like when we had Jordan Peterson and he who
he was talking about his friend and lunch bucket,
right.
Lunchbucket the guy that worked in and as soon as everyone realized that it
bothered him that they called him lunch bucket,
they've only just called him lunch bucket and then they quit because he couldn't
handle it.
So don't be if you,
if someone calls you a lunch bucket in know cool.
Yeah,
my mom makes a good sandwich,
mom makes a pretty good salary,
you know,
and then boom,
you break out the lunch bucket.
Really like,
you know,
go with it.
No,
no factor.
Yeah.
If you start freaking out about this stuff,
it's going to drive you crazy.
So yeah,
man.
So be careful.
Don't freak out about stuff if you have to learn to stand your ground a little
bit,
but don't just start snapping good dog.
Like,
yeah,
like a rabid dog.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that is a good little escalation.
That example,
the dog thinks Doosan because it's true.
I mean,
getting treated like a doormat that could look like a bunch of different things.
You know,
it's teasing.
That seems like the obvious one or whatever.
But you know,
that could be a lot of stuff that could be like,
hey,
grab me some coffee.
Yeah,
right.
Sometimes people just do that because you haven't ever said to him like,
you know,
like,
hey man,
are you ever going to get me coffee?
What's up?
You know,
you just make a joke about the same thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
We like dealing with it like as a,
you know,
if something bothers you.
So,
and I could see this maybe happening cause every once in a while,
like,
you know,
you kind of run into these scenarios where like someone does something that you,
um,
you don't really like or you don't,
I don't appreciate the way they treated me right there during that scenario.
And it sort of always happens,
but it's too small to make a big deal out of it at that time.
And when you're a agreeable person who just like,
all right,
I'm going to essentially,
I'm gonna let it slide,
whatever,
you know,
but it happens again then again,
but I'm agreeable.
I'm letting it slide.
Ha Ha.
Maybe I'll even laugh it off and whatever.
So to the other person,
they're just like,
whatever.
They're just how you said they're not thinking about it.
They're just going about their business and they're getting a laugh here and
there,
which instantly gets forgotten and whatever they keep going about their
business.
No,
no,
no factor.
Meanwhile in my head I'm like,
man,
I'm getting tired of this.
I'm straight up.
So it happens one day.
Maybe I got a little less sleep that day or something.
One teeny tiny thing from flying off the handle.
Yeah.
Hey I don't appreciate this and this and that.
You do and you always do it.
And they're like,
oh he's August.
Cause even if I did,
I didn't get any.
So then you get this little reputation.
People Act shocked as the guy says,
you know,
when I stand my ground,
it's the other person.
Just kind of like,
why are you standing your ground right now?
It doesn't make sense.
Like even if I did remember all the Times I've done this,
you were laughing the whole time.
Like it,
it doesn't compute or it's funny now that now that I think,
I think about times in my life,
like when I was younger and someone would stand their ground on me or whatever
and I'd be like,
what are you talk I'd be,
I'd be the exact person that you're talking about saying,
what are you talking about man?
Like I have no idea what you're talking about.
Yeah.
Why are you freaking out right now?
And they're like,
you always say jumps like that.
And maybe I put together like,
okay,
maybe I do make them.
Whereas now that I'm older and if someone was to freak out like that on me,
I would instantly recognize,
think to myself like,
you know what?
I probably do things that I shouldn't.
I probably,
oh yeah,
I kind of ride this person and that's why they're freaking out right now.
Yeah.
A little bit more aware of my impact and,
but in a way you sort of had to,
I mean I'm sure you've sort of,
you're sort of familiar with this,
you know,
even like painting that picture,
it's like,
it's obviously you're familiar with this,
but when it's happening to you,
you're kind of not.
But then if you have to go,
go back and do like some investigation of your whole like relationship with the
person to understand,
okay,
now I see how that could have been interpreted back last year and then maybe
three months ago and then made me last weekend.
Then we're like right now,
okay I'm after,
you know,
then it it,
but it doesn't compute naturally,
you know?
So yeah,
if you do that,
the escalating dog thing,
it'll,
it'll be more clear I think.
Yeah.
And you can stand,
there may be an escalated dog only escalate the dog scenario if you can't just
have a good time with it and relax and not worry about it.
Yeah.
Which is the primary goal.
Yes.
But being treated like a doormat,
like I said,
like if you know how like people are just so you know,
people,
a people pleaser type of person,
like in a relationship or something like,
um,
you know,
like,
uh,
hold on.
I can't think of an example.
But Kevin have a movie reference.
That's very pathetic
actually.
Anyway.
If you're like a people pleaser and you do everything for,
you know,
and then they don't do it back,
kind of thing.
Like,
Oh yeah,
you let your husband or wife or whatever,
you let them go out every Saturday just because they want to,
they want to go play poker or you know,
one of these things that,
what's the common thing that they do and they do when they come back late on
drugs.
But no,
well it'd be way worse than that.
It'll be just total like whatever you need or want.
You got it.
And then like the one time they say,
hey,
I want to go shopping on this.
They'd be like,
oh,
shopping will the,
you gotta do this,
you gotta do the kid,
you know,
like that kind of thing.
Where it's like a disproportionate like relationship,
you know,
kind of thing like that can,
I can see it can go down with those types of relationships.
You know like being at a,
you can't just laugh those things off in life.
You know,
you do have to do the escalation of text and be like,
hey,
that's a little bit more serious.
Yeah,
true.
Next question.
Hey Jocko,
I'm a business owner in the beginning stages of merging with another company.
The other company doesn't know much about what we do,
but it has the sales and marketing marketing we need just at a conference with
just at a conference call with him and it didn't go well.
They're wanting to,
the
pay structure for contractors as well as change how we build our customers.
All the,
all for the benefit of money to ching see some money on that one.
Is it not a good idea to have,
have the primary mission be about money in more so on the success of the
customer or is it good to be money motivated?
I,
I have and enjoy all your books.
Oh yeah.
That's cool.
Any advice would be helpful.
So that means you've read the dichotomy of leadership,
I hope,
because this is the answer of the day,
need to be more balanced.
Okay.
So
if you're money hungry,
right?
Which is what this is sounding like,
if you're money hungry,
correct.
If you're money hungry,
you're going to cut corners on product.
The product is going to be weak or,
or low quality,
you're going to do wrong by the customer.
Right?
Cause when you,
when you get a chance to,
you know,
the customer,
the customer placed an order,
a double word,
or by action,
they click the click thing twice and they still gonna have to pay that
restocking fee,
you know,
whatever.
Like whatever the thing is,
right?
You treat customers like that and they're gonna go,
okay,
well we don't really want to shop with you anymore.
And you end up with a bad reputation and the quality is low and no,
eventually you have no more business.
That's what's going to happen.
So,
so no,
we can't go hardcore money grubbing just,
that's our,
that's our focus.
Other end of the spectrum is,
hey,
we're paying our contractors too much.
Is that possible?
Yes,
it's possible.
You're giving your customers too much or giving them too good of a price point
and guess it was now going to happen.
Same thing.
You're going to not have a business anymore.
So one you have your business goes out of business because your cause you don't
have any business anymore because you've treated your customers badly.
The contractors don't want to work with you so you have,
you end up shutting down.
This one's opposite.
You're everyone loves you,
you just don't have any money so you're going out of business even at all.
So there has to be some balance.
Do you have to find the right balance?
That's what every company is trying to do now I would say that you would you
where you want to lean and this is probably what you're thinking.
You want to lean toward taking care of the customer.
You want to lean toward giving the contractors good value for their work.
You want to lean toward high quality.
The reason you want to lean towards those things is those are all long term
strategic pay offs,
right?
What's the short term?
The short term is take advantage of the customers.
The short term is screw over the contractors.
The short term has put out low quality stuff.
We make good profit this quarter,
but it's uh,
it's a short term win.
It's a long time,
long term loss.
So that's why I would say lean,
don't go out of control.
You can't go out of control in that direction,
but you can lean towards that direction.
Now as far as the new company,
the merger and all this stuff,
get it.
I get it.
Here's what's going to happen.
What you need to go and build good relationships with those people.
The new company,
they need to be your best friends because if you build relationships with them,
then you can have influence over these points.
If you have an antagonistic relationship and you're the new guy or whatever,
like,
Oh yeah,
the new company that you think they don't,
you're saying that they,
what does he say?
They don't know what we do.
Right?
What do you think they think?
They think you don't know what they do.
They're thinking,
you know what,
you don't even,
hey,
you guys make good money.
Might make good product,
but you can't sell anything.
And we got sales and we got marketing.
We could sell anything.
We don't care what it looks like.
We don't care what the quality is.
That's what they're thinking.
Yeah.
So you need to form a relationship with them because I will tell you with their
sales and marketing,
if you're making a good product,
that's how we get the big time when,
but if you have an antagonistic relationship with them,
uh,
it'll all fall apart and you won't have any influence at all.
And they'll be like,
you don't even know what you're talking about,
dude.
We're just going to jack the price even more and we're going to undercut our per
contractors going to get contractors competing with each other.
They're going to hate each other.
They're going to hate us,
but it doesn't matter.
Look at our bottom line.
So build some relationships there.
Next question.
I'm conflicted about where my loyalty lies.
I have a wife and two children,
but I recently took a job within federal law enforcement.
In based on my prior tactical experience,
I'll be given the opportunity to attend the two weeks selection for a position
as an operator on a fulltime tactical team that will most certainly pulled me
away from my family.
My heart is in the right place.
I know this level of sacrifice is needed in order to keep evil at bay.
However,
I believe every father feels that obligation to be at home to raise the
children.
And I'm learning that balancing duty,
responsibility,
loyalty,
commitment to family to country is hard,
hard
and maybe impossible.
All right,
so are you,
and he goes on to say that I know you have made this decision yourself.
Yeah.
And I would say to this dude,
um,
actually you are the only person that can make this decision and you're right.
I did make that decision.
I did 20 years and I at the end of 20 years decided to prioritize my family over
the military and over my own desires to cause.
Believe me,
the selfish thing is just keep getting after it.
But also what's important.
I was not good at balancing,
right.
I've,
I ranked and prioritized the teams above my family the whole time I was in and
not everyone does that.
Some people are much better at balancing that.
I did and that's how they do 30 and 32 years and 34 years and 27 years.
They figured out how to balance that better than I did.
And so it sounds like you're even raising this question indicates to me that you
probably have a decent chance of being able to be better at balancing than I do.
So there's that.
The other thing I would say is you say that the being an operator in fulltime
tactical team will most certainly pull me away from my family.
I would research that a little bit,
you know,
because sometimes when you get to a little higher level,
do you have more flexibility and you might,
might actually have time to spend with your family,
might be a little bit different.
Maybe you're on call,
whereas normally you wouldn't be on call.
But now all of a sudden you're on call,
but you're,
while you're on call,
you're at least,
you know you're,
you might be doing,
you might have more family time.
I don't know.
I can tell you that,
you know,
sometimes,
depending on the way you look at it,
you know,
if you look at the special operations community versus the conventional
community,
and it just depends on the units,
depends on a lot of things.
But sometimes,
you know,
the conventional forces going on,
uh,
you know,
16 month deployment to Iraq
and that's a long time.
Some special operations units going on for a month deployments and they'd come
home now they,
now they might do more of those over their career.
But again,
that's something you need to,
you need to find out the facts.
You need to talk to someone that's on that team and say,
Hey,
listen,
here's what's going on.
I got two sons,
they wrestle and they do Jujitsu and I like to go to those tournaments.
What's our schedule like?
How is it going to be,
you know,
and then you kind of,
you,
you can make a better assessment.
I wouldn't just assume that the tactical team has a busier schedule.
I could be wrong.
I could be completely wrong.
What you're probably the assumption you're making,
which is a decent assumption,
is that when you're part of a part of an elite tactical team,
you're going to have to input more time.
It's gonna,
it's gonna.
It's gonna mean more to you and you're going to be like,
okay,
I need to train more.
I'm going to tell you,
she trained more.
No matter what position you're in,
right.
You need to be training as much as you can.
You need to be staying sharp.
So I would do some research on that and then I would also consider this
men have been leaving their families so that they could go and fight evil since
the beginning of time,
whether it was ever going out to fight the lions
or whether they were going out to fight some awards going to invade.
Other countries are going to find treasure or whatever.
Whatever they were doing,
people have been doing it.
Even World War II guys left and there is no guarantee that they were coming
home.
They left for two,
three,
four years
goes,
that's the way it works.
There's your,
your boys are not going to be,
they're not,
their lives aren't going to be ruined if you're not there at every ballgame.
And I'll tell you there's actually,
if you do that,
your sons will learn the meaning of duty and sacrifice more than a normal kid
would.
So,
so pay attention to that too.
Again,
all that being said,
this is something that only you can make the call on because you're,
you can analyze the details of the situation and you know what if your wife
works or where your wife works or dot wife doesn't work,
that makes a big deal.
If your wife works and you're gone all the time,
that's a problem.
Now who's raising your kids?
So you got to pay attention to that.
If you,
if you both work but you both work normal jobs now you're home and you're doing
your,
you know,
you're there enough.
So just weigh these things out.
But I would,
I would get the details and then make a decision.
And you know what,
no matter what decision you make,
it's the right decision.
How's that?
That's pretty simple.
If you make a decision and you're going to go on the tactical team,
cool.
If you don't,
cool,
you're still doing federal law enforcement.
Awesome.
Keeping the,
keeping the monsters at bay.
Hmm.
Yeah.
The thing that helped me a lot that you explained early on is to tell them why
you tell people why you're doing what you're doing and thinking about the team
and in this case,
the family or whatever.
In this specific case,
probably your wife.
Yeah.
So if you're feeling that,
because I did,
I did the,
the feeling of like,
oh,
I,
I feel like I'm not being as loyal to my family because I'm like focusing on
work kind of thing.
So I'll get that from time to time,
you know,
especially if I'm like super focused and it's like,
Dang,
I didn't even think about my kids or family all day today.
You know,
I'll have that little phone,
whatever.
I'd take it.
And I used to go like four months thinking about my family.
I'm such a horrible,
well it's a sliding scale,
so,
you know,
um,
but I do know that the more I communicate with my wife and be like,
Hey,
I have to go here and I'm,
this is what I'm gonna,
I'm gonna really try to focus on this,
you know,
this week,
a video this week
and you know,
I really busy.
Oh yeah,
I'll be be so I might not be here for this and this and you know,
like I might miss this,
you know,
and just lay it all out,
why you're doing it.
You know,
how you always say,
and a lot of the Times your loyalty will be demonstrating demonstrated with
that.
You know,
like,
it's like,
Hey,
I'm doing my job.
It's the time requirements are a little bit more,
or whatever.
Like I want you to know,
like,
what can I,
can we do anything?
Can we adjust anything to make it better for everybody?
You're 100% right.
And,
and actually to take that one step further,
including your wife into the decision making process where you're like,
Hey,
listen hon this,
if I do this job,
it's going to be more,
but hey,
it's going to be super rewarding to me.
And sometimes that's enough.
You know,
you tell your wife,
this is gonna be super rewarding for me because I'm going to be able to go and
kill bad guys,
which is or protect innocent people,
which is what I want to do.
That's what I signed up for it and I'm gonna be able to do it in a,
in a more complete way.
And there's a chance your wife says,
you know what?
I know that's what you're born to do.
Go do it.
Or she might say,
listen,
you've done that already.
You know,
let's focus on the family and you.
Cool.
Yeah.
Those are both good decisions.
We're in a win win situation here.
That's the bottom line,
dude.
Yeah.
Next question,
Jocko.
I'm 19:00 AM I in my first year of college,
ever since I was 12 of dreamed about being a marine or seal.
I plan on joining up after college,
but I just got diagnosed with epilepsy.
I only have seizures in my sleep,
so I never noticed.
I always thought of serving in the military as a way that I would prove to
myself that I was a man and that it would be given my life a purpose.
Now I don't know what to do.
I hate the idea of living some comfortable life where I have a cozy nine to five
job that I only do for the money.
I want something hard and meaningful.
What should I do?
There's an infinite number of options that you have,
so you need to just pick one of those options,
find a new career of that you think looks cool,
and then go get after it and you gotta figure you want to,
you don't want a nine to five job cold.
There's all kinds of jobs that aren't nine to five.
You don't,
whether it's construction management or construction or gas,
oil or some kind of public safety,
there's all kinds of things.
I don't know if you can be a firefighter on if you can be a cop,
if you have epilepsy,
I'm not sure.
But there's all kinds of different jobs and careers and there's jobs that are
hard and there's jobs that are incredibly meaningful to our economy here.
And the more you help our economy here,
the more you help us have a positive influence in the world.
So go and figure out what job that you want to do and go crush it and go,
you don't build an empire and make a ton of money.
And then if you want to,
great,
then you can support some veterans causes and you can give back that way.
So,
so that's cool.
There's,
there's,
it's always impressive to me.
We work with all kinds of different companies and national on front.
It's always so impressive to me when I meet people from every possible industry
that you can imagine and they're completely into their job.
They are so into their job,
they're fighting world war nine like there that into it.
You know they're running intel,
the run an operation,
they're driving down.
Every dollar matters,
everything that they're doing,
they're so into it and it's awesome.
And this is everything.
This is every different industry.
I see people like that.
No,
not every person in every industry is like that.
But if you find something that you're interested is in and you jump in there and
that's going to be your vocation right now there's another part to this that is
kind of I guess like in your head or whatever.
That's like some kind of hard living that's not best,
not very difficult to come up with,
right?
Go Start Training Jiujitsu go start trading some box and go start wrestling.
Go Do Moitai go start shooting,
go start lifting and seeing how strong you can get and seeing how powerful you
can get.
Go learn to hunt and learn to hike and learn to play guitar and learn.
Just learn a bunch of stuff.
Become a force to be reckoned with.
And
you know,
the bottom line is being a seal or being in marine does not prove that you are a
man.
There are plenty of losers in both of those organizations and so don't,
you don't need some label to make you a man.
That's not what makes you a man.
Be Your own man.
Go out and conquer your part of the world.
Next question.
Two questions.
I recently attended an assessment for retraining.
Let's say one more thing.
Sorry.
Nah Man.
When things like this happen,
like when something happens to me,
well this is,
you want to hear my weird superstitious um,
view of the world.
Sure.
It's sort of,
it's sort of reminiscent of everything happens for a reason.
You've heard that.
Everyone's heard that for me,
something like this,
when something like this happens to me,
when something happens in my life that I didn't want to have happen where I
didn't expect to happen,
I get an unpleasant surprise.
I look at it and assess it like,
okay,
this is,
this is happening.
So that's something else.
This is trying to prevent something else from happening to me that I would have
been really catastrophic.
I hurt my knee the other day doing Jujitsu.
Sure.
Doing,
doing wrestling and I am on my way driving home.
I'm like,
you know what?
This is preventing me from wrecking my shoulder in two weeks or the next night I
was probably going to wreck my shoulder,
which is,
which is no a catastrophic injury in my shoulder.
That's what was about to happen to me and the powers that be knew.
The only way to get me off the mat was to hurt my knee bad enough that it pulled
me off the mat for for a couple of weeks.
So boom.
There you go.
Here you go,
Jocko.
You're welcome.
Yeah,
so something like this,
this is an indicator far as I'm concerned,
you have some bigger and better thing that you need to do some,
hey,
it wasn't this.
It's cool except it like right on.
Say thank you.
Yeah,
because there's people that they,
they,
it's not epilepsy that they have.
They have something that debilitates them from doing even things that you are
capable of doing.
So be stoked that this delivery came from wherever it comes from.
Whatever it is that you believe in,
that this dis dis God,
this happened because it's,
it's putting you on the path.
I guess that's what I'm saying.
Putting you on the path.
So who knows what you're supposed to do,
but you're supposed to do something cause you're not supposed to be a seal.
You're not supposed to be a marine.
If you were supposed to be that,
that would have happened.
It didn't happen.
That's not a bad thing.
That means there's some other door's going to open up big.
Yeah.
So that's the way I live.
I always look at injuries like that.
Positive way I can look at injuries is,
hey,
I was going to whatever I was going to like,
I was going to rip apart triple threat on my knee in four days.
So I just got a little ding to pull me off the mat.
So that doesn't happen.
Yeah.
Oh I needed rest.
Here's what you get.
Boom,
you're going to get this.
Yeah,
I'll have those thoughts do some,
like it's Kinda like,
oh,
I'm safe from injury because I'm already injured kind of thing.
Yeah.
There we go.
It's a weird feeling.
Yeah.
But that is true.
And Yeah.
And kind of like a lot of times,
and this is so good that the,
that guy,
this guy is,
he knows already I want to do something harder than meaningful brow.
I have men.
How did he say?
Old Depots 1919 man.
1990 and him,
yeah.
He's all right.
He's already on the path.
He's totally on the path and you know,
he's just discovering what doors he wants to,
you know,
what doors are open,
what windows are closed,
whatever,
you know.
And he's discovered man,
one his 19.
Yeah.
I didn't have no direction.
Did,
uh,
did I ever have the thought of,
Hey,
yeah,
I want to do something hard and meaningful.
Did I ever have that thought?
Hmm.
No,
I did not have that thought ever.
Um,
lifting weights or something like this,
but yeah,
man,
that's good.
So yeah,
I think he's ahead of the game being on time.
Yeah.
There's no,
there's no label that makes you a man.
You do your check and you're doing a good job so far,
evidently.
All right,
next question.
Two questions.
I recently attended assessment for retraining into the combat control career
field.
I'm active duty for air force in a different career field and rang the bell
during water confidence training.
How do I live with my decision and move forward?
Yeah,
and first you see there's two.
There's two questions that are basically the same question.
So that was part a and this is part B.
I do read.
Do you ARD deal hard.
Okay.
Drop on request.
Gotcha.
Rang the bell.
Same thing.
Ideal card from buds.
Class three Oh three I went,
went on to be a s a r core corpsmen.
Star swimmer starts when requirements,
so he was okay.
He was a rescue swimmer.
Okay,
but it's tea,
but it's taken until recently to regain the desire to live and even strive to
work out again.
What can you do when you realize a life path you've chosen was not only wrong,
but you never feel like you found a new path.
To me,
this,
this question to both these questions are kind of similar to the previous one,
right?
And I can tell you,
being a,
being a seal or being a combat controller is not the be all end all.
And the bottom line is it wasn't for you.
It wasn't free.
It wasn't even either.
One of you guys just wasn't for you.
And the fact that matter is,
it's not for most people.
It's not normal.
There's an 80% attrition rate of butts.
Most people quit.
Good people.
I was down there the other day and I was talking to one of my buddies that runs,
runs,
it,
runs
the,
he's a civilian reason.
One of the civilians that works there,
but he was,
we were talking about,
you know what it was about butts,
and I forget what even led into it,
but he pointed at the,
you know,
when you,
when you quit bloods,
you put your helmet by the bell.
And so as more and more people quit,
more and more helmets are on up and there'll be hundreds of helmets lined up and
he's like,
you see those helmets right there?
And I'm like,
yeah.
He goes,
every single one of those kids was a stud
and when I went through it wasn't quite like that because not everyone knows.
Showing up at buds in the 90s
was a stud.
The they weren't because we didn't know what was happening.
We didn't know.
We didn't know how to do a pullup workout.
We couldn't look online and see a program on how to get better at rope climbs.
We didn't know that you had to swim with fins.
We didn't know.
I didn't know why I didn't do anything when I showed up to buds.
So these kids now they know everything and so what do they do?
They prepare all of them at a minimum.
I would say the minimum guy prepared now is probably prepared at least as good
as the most prepared guy.
Actually.
That's probably,
that's probably inaccurate.
I bet you the minimum,
the least prepared guy entering buds right now is probably still more prepared
than the most prepared guy that went to buds when I went through now.
So,
so my point in saying that is most of those people that are studs quit,
most of those people that join the navy,
that signed on a dotted line and commit six years of their life because there's
nothing more they want to do than be a seal.
And most of them don't make it through.
So it's not for everyone.
And then you know what?
You one guy in the air force,
one guy in the navy,
you did your job,
you do what you're supposed to do,
a corpsman,
whatever your normal career field was in the air force and you served your
country and you did what the country needed you to do.
The country needs you to do whatever job you did.
The country needed you to do that job.
So thank you for your service.
And now you go and find something else.
You go and find a new mission
and the same things here,
like you,
you want to get better with your life.
So what do you do?
You work and you build and you study and you get an awesome physical condition
and you trained Jujitsu and you become a doctor or a firefighter,
EMT,
you're a cop.
And there's whichever way that you figure out that you can serve,
you become a business person.
You go and work,
construction,
whatever it is that you do,
you'd go and do it.
You do it hard and you don't get caught up in a title.
Right?
So this is another thing that's kind of reflects back to what we were talking
about earlier.
Seals don't care that you weren't a seal.
You know,
like it's not like seals are walking around,
oh,
this person wasn't a seal.
I don't respect him.
This person wasn't a single,
We don't care.
It's a vocation.
It's a job.
So you're not,
I don't look down on people that weren't seals.
It's just that was my job.
You had a different job,
right?
It's like,
it's like Jujitsu.
I don't look down on people that don't train Jujitsu.
I look at him like,
Hey,
you should,
because that's a choice,
but let me rephrase that.
I don't look down on people that I can beat in Jujitsu because I know for a fact
all it is is that I've been training longer than them and once they train longer
than me,
there'll be able to beat me.
That's the way it works.
So people that were in the seal teams aren't looking down on you because you
weren't,
they don't care.
I don't know.
Thinking about it.
So when I meet a cop,
when I meet a firefighter,
when I meet a business person,
I respect what they're doing with their life.
If they're getting after it,
I don't care what arena it's in,
man.
I know some,
I'm so lucky right now working at national on front,
we meet people that are just just awesome humans that are crushing their field.
And if they were in the seal teams,
they'd be crushing that field.
But they didn't.
They went to,
they went and did what they did.
They went in the finance world.
They went in the construction world,
they went in the gas,
oil business.
Whatever they did,
they did.
And they're getting after it.
So that's what you need to do.
You quit in the past,
you rang the bell.
No one cares
unless you quit now.
So get up,
go find a new mission and get after it,
man.
Get after it.
Next question.
You've been unfairly wronged by a brother objectively,
you aren't getting the full apology that you expect it.
The beef is over now and he treats you well.
But how do you psychologically reframe and kill that lingering resentment?
Unfairly wronged by a brother.
Interesting brothers.
Don't wrong brothers.
We'll start with that.
So this dude wasn't actually abro.
A brother might've been a bro,
but he wasn't a brother.
Make little distinction there is that distinction ever been made before?
I don't think on this platform and they've been making it cool.
There was like,
Hey,
this guy's my bro,
it's all good.
And then there's like,
this guy's my brother.
My brother is not going to wrong me.
My Bro might,
but my brother's not going to wrong me so that he,
so if it happens and some guy,
like I said,
if somebody that you consider your brother wrongs you,
then they'd clearly you,
you overestimated their
commitment.
So here's what's gonna happen with me.
Number one,
it's noted,
noted.
That's my,
that's my ultimate,
that's my ultimate satisfaction.
Right.
When I know when it's,
when I note something,
yeah.
Oh,
it's like,
oh this is the kind of person he is noted.
Now I got him.
Yeah.
Now I got this person marked.
So trust is not going to be reestablished for a long,
long time,
if ever.
Right.
I'm not going to like this person clearly,
but here's the deal.
All that mistrust and all that dislike and all that is going to be internal,
but we'll keep it inside
because you know what?
I'm going to have those inside them and harbor that.
I'm going to harbor those things.
Even this resentment,
I'm going to harbor it cause I can't,
I can't just make it go away.
You,
ew,
you wronged me.
It's going to be there.
Yeah.
But you know what?
I'm a professional externally,
I'm a professional.
Even if we're not in business or even if you're just like,
Hey,
I trained you,
just do it.
This guy,
right?
I'm a professional,
so I'm not going to let his little maneuvers get me externally worked up about
it.
It's not happening.
You don't get control of my emotions like that.
Externally,
you might control them inside,
but I won't let you see that ever.
So I'm a professional.
I'm normal face.
That's where I'm coming at you from just normal face.
Hey,
all good.
Oh yeah.
And you know what's interesting?
This behavior.
So when you screw me over and then I just go,
okay,
check,
noted.
And then I don't give you a reason to like hate me and then you kind of owe me.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
You're going to owe me.
So there's that and there's a,
there's a fine line.
Like if you screw me over and then I just allow it to happen and it was a,
it was a,
uh,
a legitimate violation,
well then there might be have to be repercussions,
right?
Yeah.
It sounds like this did not warrant repercussions because you know there's
certain situations if somebody wrongs you in certain ways,
there has to be repercussions.
To me.
Normally most of the time the repercussions and the best revenge that you can
take is,
is to ignore now perform and be successful in rock on and forget about them and
forget they even existed.
That to me is the best possible way to go because why would you let somebody
interfere?
Why would you commit any time,
effort,
resources to revenge when I would,
the better thing to do is commit those time,
resources,
energy to success,
to winning.
Yeah,
I'm going to do that.
But if this merits some sort of repercussions,
okay,
then those get carried out and if those get carried out,
well then we're,
we're,
we're kind of settled.
But he says you didn't get the full apology.
You expect it to,
okay.
Hey,
guess what?
People are arrogant.
Yeah.
That's the way it is.
They don't think the guy didn't even think he did anything wrong.
Most likely he's not even apologizing for it.
Barely.
So that's what I do.
I'm just going to keep it professional.
I'm going to,
you're going to be subconsciously indebted to me whether you know it or not.
Yeah,
you probably know it.
You'll probably feel it cause I'm just going to be like,
okay,
cool.
Yeah,
we'll move on.
But man,
you know,
the thing is,
this is,
this sort of goes back to that other kind of topic today.
Like this guy isn't going around thinking about you,
so why are you thinking about him?
Let's move on man,
let's move forward.
And that seems like a big part of it,
right?
Like that seems like he was you.
He says you aren't,
you aren't getting the full apology.
You know,
like I remember on that Seinfeld,
that apology dude,
I was talking to someone,
I was talking to someone like a blanket apology and I was talking to someone
that we both know who's we'll say up a public figure.
Sure.
And this individual was reading youtube comments and getting legitimately like
emotionally distraught about the whole night.
Yeah.
And was trying to talk to me about it.
And like I said,
man,
I literally do not care.
I'm like,
I do not care.
Like this is no factor.
You don't need to warn me.
You don't need to tell me.
You know what I need to look out for.
Like I literally don't care.
I mean,
if someone writes a good youtube comment of good,
it's funny.
That's great.
If they write an amine one,
cool.
I find that those are funny too.
I'm not,
I'm not worried about the person that wrote the youtube comment isn't thinking
about me.
You know,
they're not dry.
They're not,
they're not reviewing it again,
writing it again and you know,
like they don't care.
I'm not getting all caught up in this stuff.
Don't get caught up in these petty things.
You know,
I did that.
We talked about this on the podcast of,
of,
of the black belt.
The black belt doesn't care about things that don't matter.
You can grab the black belts.
Shoulder Eve is g and he doesn't care because he knows that doesn't mean
anything.
There's no,
there's no,
there's no factor.
So you want to,
that's,
that's what you want to do.
You want to,
you don't want to care about things that don't matter.
You don't invest your time and energy.
Things don't matter.
The guy wronged you.
Cool.
Noted.
You know that he's kind of a kind of,
uh,
a devious dude.
You know that it's noted.
Cool.
Move on.
No,
I'm not worried about it.
Am I going to put my trust in him again?
Nope,
but that's cool cause I know other people to trust.
Yeah.
Let's not get wrapped around these little things,
man.
Let's,
let's,
let's rise above and get some black flag going here.
Let's rise above.
I still wonder what kind of apology.
I totally cut you off.
So sorry about that.
Yeah,
no,
it was a Seinfeld thing.
It didn't matter the,
I'm wondering why at the same time what you're saying.
I agree.
But I do wonder what kind of apology he got.
You know,
cause he didn't get the full apology.
Yeah.
Partial yet.
So,
well,
partial apology that can come in many forms.
It's probably the most common form of a partial apology.
Has a button on it.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
We need swing by and pick the other than the up the other night.
But I just didn't even know that you wanted to come.
Yeah,
it was my fault.
I'm sorry.
But yeah,
it was partially your fault kind of thing.
And then there's the other one that's like,
I'm sorry you felt that way,
you know?
You know that one.
Where's the cat?
I'm sorry you felt that,
that I was attacking you.
You know?
But you know,
I didn't mean to kind of thing where it's kind of like,
hey,
you're,
because the prison doesn't want an apology for necessarily the actual words you
said it was.
It was like what you did.
Like you attacked me with whatever you said,
you know,
kind of thing.
So you can't just say,
hey,
I can't,
I'm sorry.
You forgot.
That's right.
Sorry.
I'm sorry that you felt that way.
You know,
that is a pretty backhanded sort of,
yeah,
same thing,
but the but the one you say,
but I'm sorry,
but you know,
I didn't know that's kind of like,
I'm sorry but I'm not fully so yeah,
that's the same.
It's the same with extreme ownership.
Yes.
Some people saying,
you know,
look,
I'm in charge of the team and this was definitely,
I'm in charge of team when I'm in charge.
Then when things go wrong,
it's my fault.
But I'll tell you what,
as soon as I get that,
I'm always thinking,
I was saying about,
sorry,
sorry.
Yeah.
And my wife from time to time,
there are no excuses.
Yeah.
There's maybe think about it when you get somebody that actually believes in
extreme ownership.
There is,
there are no buts on anything that they say.
And strange living kind of I guess coincident,
not coincident.
I ran a nine year old daughter who will not allow you to make an excuse.
They're old daughter.
Yeah.
She will call you out if you throw a button or you say,
well,
I didn't know when we had to be there.
Oh.
So you're not taking ownership.
Yes.
Much.
And make,
yeah,
totally makes sense.
And if you,
it's strangely like if you do it without the,
but you know,
when you do it,
just full speed,
even if in your head you believe,
but you know what I mean.
Let's face it,
man.
You had to come into you kind of thing.
Yeah.
Just keep it,
because that's not what you're doing when you apologize.
That's,
that's separate from the apology.
You know,
it's like you're including this stuff,
unwarranted stuff with your apology.
You don't do that.
Give a good apology.
[inaudible] is the worst thing is,
is it's so obvious and it makes everyone so mad.
Oh yeah.
The receiving end of that is so mad.
Right.
And you think that it's,
you think that it's improving your position.
Yeah.
You're explaining,
look,
look a echo.
I'm really sorry that you showed up to record and,
and I wasn't there and I didn't let you know,
but yeah.
But I didn't really,
I didn't remember texting you or whatever,
like,
but you know,
you should have told me that you were heading.
That's so that's what I worry about.
But you should have told me that we were definitely recording cause you didn't
really get back to me.
Yeah.
Like why would I say that?
All's I'm doing is,
you know what's funny is people always tweet me when a sports coach,
they tweet me when a sports coach either takes ownership or doesn't overtly,
it's not overtly because some guys,
some sports coaches say,
hey look,
I'm the coach.
I made some bad calls out there.
We're going to get back in the drawing room.
I'm going to get this thing fixed.
And if it goes,
man,
this guy's awesome.
And it's just so funny.
Everyone says this guy is awesome.
He's taking ownership.
Yeah.
Even people that aren't even people will retweet something that people aren't
saying.
He's taking extreme ownership.
Someone will say,
oh it's good to see a coach taking full responsibility or whatever.
They'll tell you,
use your own word for it.
Right.
And then some other knucklehead,
we'll,
we'll say you who I am,
I am the coach and I am responsible for the team.
But if I got players that aren't going to put out there in the first quarter,
I'm not the one on the field.
You know,
you,
you got to carry out this totally embarrassing for,
and everyone says,
hey,
you might want to learn how to take ownership.
And that's where people,
so it's so obvious and yet we still do it.
It may still throw out the butts.
We still want to clarify our position.
Yeah,
don't clarify your position.
Say sorry.
Take ownership.
That's it.
My wife will watch these.
Uh,
what do you call it?
The housewives one.
Not The show.
Like the reality show ones,
you know,
the whatever housewives of wear and men riddled.
I think that's why she watches it.
Just to see the train wreck.
I think that's what I think this is like the suspicion.
But men.
Yeah,
they,
they're all arguing with each other and then w you know,
they're crying and then one will say,
they'll just,
they'll say the perfect example of the non-apology,
you know,
every single time man,
it's like,
it hurts your heart to watch,
but you kind of like,
he kind of did it.
I wonder,
I wonder if this,
cause this is what happened with this guy.
Just,
I just figured it out right now.
I really don't know.
But this is what I think happened.
Okay.
We're going to be theoretical scenario.
Every single girl by relationship,
there was a what?
A girl guy relationship,
you know,
boyfriend,
girlfriend scenario.
You know,
maybe this guy got drunk,
the bro,
the brother Bro,
whatever that drunk maybe hit on the girl,
maybe something happened,
maybe something did it.
Oh.
And then it was like,
hey man,
sorry about what I did with Christine last that I was super hammered this,
but I was super hammered.
Yeah,
exactly right.
And that's the big one.
That's a big butt in the apology.
You know,
we all had,
I remember one tend to,
someone I won't go into.
It doesn't matter,
but it's a big one.
It's a big deal.
Or it's a big common one.
Where it wronged by a brother for,
no,
it was my blank parent's friend.
Okay.
Let's lady.
And she,
like she was talking,
she was talking shit about my mom to my dad and I was there,
they're hammered or whatever,
like some thing and she's like totally talking shit,
talking about this.
I'm going to do it,
I'm going to do it.
So I'm like,
whatever.
I'm like a tea,
maybe 15,
16 years old,
uh,
maybe,
maybe 30,
I don't know,
whatever.
But you know,
a teenager,
I wasn't like a three year old,
you know,
so I heard and I knew what she was talking about.
It was,
he was rude.
He was on coolest on the sat as we say.
And so I'm like,
cool.
I go home and I tell my mom straight up,
so my mom's like,
oh,
whoa,
okay.
You know,
it tells me Dad,
blah,
blah.
My Dad tells the lady,
and the Lady of course is all like,
oh no,
you know,
like I did this and you know,
so she comes to me and she says,
sorry,
right,
like,
sorry for this area.
But we had a,
you know,
we had a lot to drink or whatever and all this stuff.
And I remember feeling that like,
how are you?
Like how does this make it better?
You know,
when you're like,
well,
we had some thinking there and I didn't know anything about drinking.
I don't know what it made you sort of do.
I didn't really know at that time.
So to me it was like,
wait,
so wait,
when you drink,
like you can do that kind of stuff or what?
Like what's the deal in the apology just basically bounced off me like bullets
off of superman or something.
Yeah,
no,
Apollo,
he don't put the butts on those things.
So that's what happened with this guy.
That's what I think possible.
But it is his responsibility,
like you said,
to be like,
Hey,
I can't hold onto this thing.
You know?
Like what'd he say?
How do you psychologically reframing and kill that lingering resentment thing is
the,
it's like a scar you have to take.
He's like,
Ma,
keeping it a wound.
You got to man at it.
Yeah,
and you gotta be like,
that's just a scar.
It's like,
sure,
our relationship is different now.
It's a scar now,
but man,
I got more important things to think about or do whatever.
Yeah.
If he can pull that up that often because move on.
Next question.
Hello,
and thank you sir.
I'm an inner city math teacher in Oh gee.
Hardcore kid.
Right?
I successfully approach to my students as a team that I am the leader of.
How do I discipline some of my key players and at the same time boost or at
least not lower
morale.
Awesome.
Well that's cool.
I would say this.
If you've got kids in the classroom and he got key players in the classroom,
do what I always say to do to people.
Put them in charge of stuff,
man.
Put them in charge.
Put these kids in charge of things in the class,
not just dumb stuff.
Either not just clean up,
not just sweeping the floor,
but some legitimate stuff like,
hey,
I want you to come up with a lesson plan for tomorrow.
Here's the book that we're looking at.
Here's the pages I want you to talk about.
Dang,
I want you to lead the discussion that we're going to have in class.
Hey,
once you go over how you've solved this math problems tomorrow,
you got,
you got some of the problems wrong on the test.
I want to teach them to you and I want you to teach the class because obviously
I didn't do a good job.
Maybe you can do a better job than me and you know what you you,
you're kind of you kind of loud.
Let's put that to use.
I know people listen to you.
Here's another thing,
kid.
The kids look at,
look at you and they look up to you.
Yeah,
let's use that.
Let's try and get kids moving in the right direction.
Yeah,
so that's what I would do in a situation like this.
If someone's actually getting in trouble,
I wouldn't,
you don't do this.
You don't do what I'm talking about because they're in trouble.
Right.
That's a little bit,
you can't say you're in trouble.
So you're going to have to teach classes tomorrow.
No,
no,
no.
That doesn't work.
You say you say,
Hey,
you let that whatever they got punished for you use,
you know,
your punishment.
That could be something like taking out trash.
Yeah,
but you don't want to throw leadership at someone when they get in trouble.
Occasionally you can't do it.
Occasionally you can be like,
okay,
you know what?
You're in charge of the platoon for this week or for these four days of Admin
and all of a sudden,
yeah,
you realize,
Oh,
you got to come in at five o'clock in the morning.
you got to stay until 1800 at night.
Oh,
you've got these reports do.
Oh yeah.
It's like all these things that you didn't think about.
That's what you gotta do.
And when you get off that restriction and you get out of that role,
you realize,
hey,
I have a little respect for the boss because I realized what the boss is going
through.
So that's what I would do.
Have some fun with this.
Put the kids in charge of stuff.
Give them little assignments.
Make them get up.
Make them turn them into leaders.
Hmm.
Tournament in leaders.
Check where you think one more.
One more.
What do you do when you fail and how do you handle it?
What do you do when you fail?
You know,
recently we reviewed that US army field manual on here from like World War Two
era and it says in that manual it says,
other than death,
all failure is psychological
other than deaf.
All failure is psychological.
Think about that.
Just just think about that.
This failure,
this upset,
this,
this catastrophe.
If you aren't dead,
dead,
it's just psychological.
It's in your head.
No,
this does not mean that you won't lose some battles because you will.
We all will,
right?
But it does mean that as long as you don't surrender,
as long as you don't give up,
as long as you don't quit,
then you haven't.
Failed.
Just means you've made a temporary tactical retreat means you've made a,
a brief withdraw so that you can regroup
and we attack.
Yeah.
So as far as I'm concerned,
if you get beat,
unless you're dead,
you are not defeated and you have not failed.
What you've done is you've learned,
you've,
you've gained experience
and you're still alive.
Thank you.
Have Memories to make.
So get up
and go get after it.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So Echo Charles.
Yes.
Speaking of
getting after it.
Sure.
Getting after it.
Can you help us in that category?
Yes.
So we are on the path part of them.
Part of that path,
like we always say is Jujitsu.
It's funny how like you'll say,
Judy,
like when you suggest someone to,
to,
or your suggestion for someone to like move on or to like,
you know,
get out of a ride or whatever you always said you did too.
Yes.
And rightly so.
It,
it's one of those things men where I,
I've,
I'm not a psychologist.
Yeah,
I know you know that.
But I think that it'll cure various levels of depression.
Real.
Hey,
I've taken a lot of flack over that.
Yeah.
I think Joe Rogan,
sure.
When I was on his knee and we were basically saying like a workout,
you know,
feel better and everyone got all mad.
Right.
But the funny thing is,
Tim Ferriss,
who's actually gone through that kind of depression will tell you the exact same
thing.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Workout,
workout and do Jujitsu.
Jujitsu for sure.
Yeah,
it's crazy with you don't why I'd say,
dude,
it's even more than just like a regular workout,
whatever that even means.
But um,
is because you have a challenge that's a little bit more obviously like you
against like an obvious challenge,
you know,
and true against the person.
There's that.
Okay.
And then there's the physical part of it,
of course,
like the workout part of it,
which isn't one of the best workouts.
Like if I wanted to like lose 30 pounds,
right.
For,
I don't know,
whatever,
if I want to lose 30 pounds,
like bad pounds.
Right.
So I,
you know,
and right now,
as of right now,
there's no way I would do like a a weight loss workout.
Yeah.
I would just do regular weight lifting and I would just do more Jujitsu.
That's it.
100% like why would you son's cruising?
I mean do you do to is such a good workout.
Yeah.
Why would you work out muscles that you didn't know you had your whole body to?
By the way,
whole Bot.
Yeah.
Even your jaw muscles.
Yup.
Yeah.
True Story.
Oh yeah.
Everything.
Especially you with the job muscles because you're spending a lot of time on the
quarter of the bat talking
Ceasarean or coincidentally,
that's another part of it is what I was about to say.
So aspect 800 for you.
For everybody,
right.
Okay.
Yeah,
for you too and have a little conversation.
Oh yeah.
Post training.
Yeah.
Even like between rounds,
whatever.
It's like you're doing it and sure you can do that at the gym kind of,
but it's different.
And what we do people to want to talk before training,
I protest that you're high protest it.
I stopped the dark,
start the clock.
He's gonna be okay if I'm in a rounds are rolling.
You guys are rolling people.
There's enough of this chitty chatter.
Here's how prevalent the social element is.
He's looking at you.
No,
no,
no.
And you'll agree with it because it happens with you too.
So you ever like shaking kits,
clock started,
you shake hands with the person and then you just sneak in one question to the
person.
Like socially,
no,
not all the time because like you remember like I'll do it with Greg,
I'll do with you.
So you don't joke about that.
Oh like we'll talk about our day like Andy and I will joke about.
Yeah.
Like beep clock starts and it's like how was work today dude.
Yeah,
but that happens.
Basically what it means is neither one of us feels like trainings and still
loves laugh and then we'll train.
Right?
Cause we won't,
we won't actually have a conversation.
Right.
But see how you know that it's an easy thing.
It's you all so much that you make jokes about it.
Yes it is.
That's how social it is.
You know,
you can only just got to tighten my belt and adjust my g and put my knee pads
back up and you know what I mean?
Cause another stalling tactics.
Not very social,
but yeah,
it's stalling for sure.
Um,
but and there's a lot of benefits to this thing that we call Jujitsu.
The Shit.
Anyway,
that's a side note anyway.
When you're doing,
do you use to,
of course you need a geek cause you're doing g,
n Nogi.
So when you get your key,
what gains are we getting?
Are we getting the best skis?
Are we getting the Juncus keys?
We're getting the best keys,
correct?
Oh yeah.
Big Time.
Anyway.
The best cookies are origin gies.
You get them@originmain.com or [inaudible] dot com the all kinds of stuff.
All kinds of clothes.
Including jeans.
Yes.
American debt,
which you know what even like not everyone does Jujitsu.
Not everyone does Gigi Jitsu,
but everyone does have jeans.
Now let me ask you the same question you asked me.
What kind of genes are we getting best?
Not,
the junk is not the junk.
What'd you say?
Juncus junk.
Kista that's not even a word.
Yes it is.
It is.
The junkiest kind.
If something is junk.
Oh you know what?
Johnson,
either one of those subtle differences in,
in,
remember how I told you in co in Hawaii they're like subtle differences in
words.
They're only small.
They're pretty much the same,
but there's subtle differences.
One of them that is one of them,
like junkies,
like little pigeon.
Yeah.
As a little pigeon.
Cause it would be junkiest right.
Not Jumping up.
Exactly right.
So junk is the same as junky.
Like it's this,
it's like in the mainline,
you say junky.
Like it's more of a,
what do you call it?
Like not a verb,
but um,
uh,
oh yeah.
I like that.
That hamburger is real,
real junkie.
Right?
So junk on the mainland,
the word junk is a noun.
It's a junk.
It's a piece of junk.
It's a pile of junk.
It's a,
now in Hawaii it's a,
it's an adjective.
Like it's junk.
Like that's a way of describing it.
No,
no,
no.
See it sounded like a noun to you because you're from the mainland.
If you say John,
that's why you can have words like it's a junker way more general way
more junk.
Like we don't want the jug because there's such thing as junk Juncker and
junkiest in Hawaii and here it's like no,
it's just junk.
It's either junk or it's like not junk.
You don't kind of thing cause it's no,
see what I'm saying?
Like I said,
these differences are subtle of follow though.
Yeah,
I know.
Cause I thought of like if you went,
if I said,
hey,
what's that stuff on the side of your house over there echo,
you'd be like,
oh that's just junk right up pilot junk.
And I get what you mean by that.
It's in a lawn chair.
It's the old weed wacker that doesn't work anymore.
Right?
Yeah.
There's a couple of stuffed animals that no one wants to be more.
That's junk.
Yes.
What you're saying is,
hey,
how's that car that you just bought?
Yeah.
How's it work?
How is it?
Is that thing?
Nope.
Is it dope?
And you're like,
no,
it's junk.
It's junk.
How was that movie last night?
Kind of junk.
Yeah.
Okay.
So in regards to jeans,
you don't want the junk gene or in your case the junky or junkiest genes,
junk kist is what you said.
Caress the whole,
the Ko.
Why version whole lot.
Yes.
That's how,
um,
nonetheless,
no,
you want the best ones.
Get the origin jeans and whatever other clothes and don't forget about
supplements to supplements,
joint warfare,
Krill oil discipline,
discipline,
go discipline.
Go for when you need a little kick.
And,
and uh,
it's interesting,
you and I have both morphed to a situation where discipline,
the drink is just the normal.
That's just part of the world.
That's just part of it.
I am now drinking and this is the thing about discipline.
It doesn't have 480 grams of,
or 480 milligrams of caffeine.
Yeah.
In fact,
it has 15 grams per scoop.
This is not the crazy stimulant that's like,
let's face it,
Jujitsu,
you don't want to be all amped up on caffeine going to your class.
How do you do?
That's why discipline is so good.
Pre Roll.
You know,
so that's what I figured out now.
Cause if you have ice tea,
which I used to drink a lot of ice tea drink Jocko white tea,
right.
You just drink that stuff.
Right?
Like think of when you were a kid,
all going to have some ice tea that had caffeine in it.
Right.
You weren't freaking out.
That has way more caffeine in discipline.
So what I'm saying is discipline is now just sort of a,
it goes to just a day long,
like an all day.
I must have had,
I must have had five bottles of discipline today.
Dang.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's just horrible day because I'm sitting there drinking it.
You know,
I'm,
I'm working.
Yeah.
I'm writing,
I'm editing,
which,
which
let's face it like it writing and editing sometimes is a real chore and Mental
Chore.
Not Fun.
Yeah.
So you've got to get in no game.
That's why I've been drinking a lot,
had been disciplined lately because a lot of writing,
a lot of mental thought.
Yeah.
So anyways,
I don't know,
the mega mix for Jujitsu is discipline.
Okay.
Water.
You can actually add like a little,
like a,
maybe like a third
cup,
whatever the third of your mix total of like a cranberry juice or like,
um,
you can squeeze lemon juice in there or something.
Okay.
Water,
lemon juice,
discipline and on it has these like minerals and electrolytes mix one scoop of
that.
Boom.
That's the Jujitsu mega mix.
There you go.
Brad,
to bring you through,
go to do two scoops of discipline.
Three.
If you want to get nuts,
you got to add more water,
you know,
and then you've got that situation going on.
Whatever's been times where I've made discipline shots.
Oh,
okay.
You're like,
I know like,
Hey,
okay.
You know what I'm heading to do Jujitsu.
I,
I'm going to be there in three minutes.
No.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm just going to mix up a little shot.
It's got three scoops and it's,
it's like a shot.
Yeah.
So I've done that before,
but that's also why mint discipline go.
Yeah,
because just when glow is for those situations where you don't want to drink a
bunch,
but you just want that hit her.
Yeah.
But the go the pill that takes longer though,
right?
Cause it's not instant.
It's instant.
That's what I tasted.
Salvation like I don't know,
half an hour,
40 minutes prior to event situation evolution.
It's like,
yeah,
the evolution it mine I feel like is or it is straight up.
It's like a routine.
You know how like you sort of have a routine.
I know.
Yes.
You know some,
some people do.
I got some routines and um,
when you call,
yeah,
the protocol comes into play like this.
You go boom,
okay I got you did x x time.
Right.
I leave the house at x time minus whatever I drink the mega mix x time minus
whatever minus,
you know,
another 10 minutes.
So it's like the,
the,
the amount of time it takes to mix it out and you just tell me when to drink it.
If they're going to roll or do something active.
Oh the thing is,
I don't want to say 40 minutes,
my half an hour,
40 minutes,
half an hour,
40 minutes or half an nine as I leave the house.
So I'll have my costs.
That's how long it take to get here.
15 between 15 and 20 minutes.
So what'd you don't need it to kick in right when you get here?
Cause going to be chat with people for the first half hour,
correct?
Yes.
Yeah.
It's one of those things,
it's not like there's this little teeny tiny window of it working,
but once it's in the,
in the system you're rolling.
Oh yeah.
I you don't even really like feel it like wear off or nothing like a coffee
crash or nothing like that.
So I don't know.
I just do it that way.
That's been,
and it's worked.
Like,
man,
I'll,
I won't not do it that way,
honestly.
What is 100%?
Uh,
also don't forget about milk,
which is if you need extra protein,
which you do,
you can get it from milk or if you just want a straight up desert,
you just have dessert.
And if you don't think the strawberry milk tastes like dessert,
you're wrong.
You know,
the strawberry milk is dessert.
Get some.
And some of the other ones,
I've just had so much of them.
I'm just really stoked on the strawberry right now.
Mint,
you know what it was your goto peanut butter or is it meant Mitt but all I'll
interchange for a variety of whatever that strategy everyone came in.
Thanks Brian for that by the way.
So it's like,
okay.
You know,
strawberry slayer,
there's a lot of height.
Yeah,
it's strawberry.
Cool.
I'm not the hugest.
Um,
like I like,
I like the struggle.
I like it.
Yeah.
But when there's chocolate,
like why would you do strawberry?
You know,
if you have chocolate or whatever.
So I'm like,
but whatever.
Let's do it.
The strawberry,
which is somewhat mixed it up,
boom,
the same deal.
I didn't want to like add extra stuff in there.
I just thought I wanted the raw deal.
So I had regular milk and strawberry milk.
See what the hype is all about.
Surprisingly,
surprisingly good meaning,
and I don't,
you know,
that's a general term,
surprisingly good or whatever.
To me,
the strawberry milk tastes closer to an actual strawberry milkshake.
The only difference that I could detect is that it's not as like overtly sweet
as like one from like,
uh,
you know,
like you get a strawberry milkshake place,
it just wasn't as sweet as that.
That's it.
Put another half a scoop in there and you'll be in the zone.
That's what I thought.
And that's what I figured out when you want.
So I,
I,
I implemented the,
that hitter,
the real litmus test,
right?
So what do you call in the list of the kits and have them sit down and I was
like,
all right,
I'm here.
This is strawberry milk.
Have something,
just a little thing.
So here's how you do it.
You don't say it easily good,
is it not good?
Because if they're not into you want more,
you don't even ask that.
You just wait.
So,
because if you ask,
hey,
is it good or not good though?
If they're old enough,
they'll tell you what you want to hear.
They'll be like,
yeah,
good.
Then they'll go play or they won't be into the tests at all,
which typically they're not.
And they'll just be like,
no,
it's junk.
Therefore,
you know,
in their mind he won't give me any more or whatever.
You know,
you just don't get an actual action,
uh,
an accurate reading.
So what you do see here,
you can have some of this.
That's it.
So they tasted both of them wanted more.
Both of them.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
Really good stuff.
So,
and also don't forget you got warrior kid milk that comes in strawberry and
chocolate as well.
And it's,
it's,
it's like a legitimately good for your children.
So get it for him.
Oh yeah.
Also Jocko white tea.
Yes.
Chuck West some teeth called Jocko white tea and it just is like drinking
goodness.
That's what it is.
Drinking victory.
Drinking tastes like,
tastes like victory and it's just goodness.
Got Antioxidants,
get you little,
gets you a little kicker certified organic too,
by the way.
Yeah.
So that's that.
Anyway,
really cool.
Origin main.com.
I forgot to say that.
Yes.
Also Jocko has his own store Jocko store.
So you go to Jocko store.com.
This is where you can get your discipline equals freedom,
shirts,
hoodies,
lightweight end,
heavyweight hats.
You anyway,
hats.
No,
you know,
no heavyweight hats.
Um,
you know,
but you do have those trucker hats with the,
what do you call it?
Snap back or flex fit.
So some options there anyway.
Anyway,
you want to represent the path.
You can get something there.
Rash guards as well.
You just do or whatever you're doing.
Boom,
you can get it.
One of those shirt that says good on it,
that does not have head on it.
Which is a positive thing.
Moving in a different direction.
More subtle direction.
I don't necessarily agree because I think that the one with your hand on it is
like,
cause not very subtle bro at all.
But it does like,
no,
they both have their benefits because look,
when I wear the good one,
just,
just good.
Like the people who do say something,
they're just kinda like,
oh yeah,
good,
good.
They'll just say it.
You know?
But the one with your head,
they'll either ask,
oh who is that on your shirt?
Like who is that?
Usually it's like,
I don't know,
you know,
Winston Churchill or I don't know where a public figure in there.
So they're wondering who is that and why the [inaudible] forgot to do that.
Now the first thing that came to me,
and I've never seen a Winston Churchill tee shirt,
but I'm glad that we got that going
nonetheless.
Or they'll know who you are and they know that that's what you say.
And they'll be like,
you know,
what do you call it?
The book that when they know and you know,
and if eds exactly right.
So I dig both 100%,
but nonetheless,
a lot of cool stuff on there.
If you,
uh,
if you like something,
get something as they say,
also subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already on iTunes and stitcher and
wherever you listen to podcasts,
because a lot of places they're trying to kind of change the landscape of
podcasts,
listening to,
by the way,
they want to charge money or something and put it behind the fire wall.
Pay,
I think it's paywall pay wall,
maybe the firewall to firewall,
the paywall.
Anyways,
we're free.
We're free.
Yeah,
free.
But nonetheless,
hey,
it is what you have to pay.
You know what you have to pay,
you have to listen to this part of the podcast is you don't actually even have
to do,
it's like one of those little trays and forget about the warrior kid podcast,
which is also not behind a paywall and it's free for your children.
If your kids want to learn how to be on the path,
your kids want to learn about discipline.
If your kids want to learn how to handle bullying and trouble in school and
trouble study,
if they want to learn to handle all that stuff in life and if you want to get a
look into cause you know you need it,
get some of that warrior kid podcast.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
Also,
Irish oaks ranch.com this is where you can get where kids soap,
which is not for kids.
It's actually Jocko soap made by a warrior kids.
That is where you could still call Jocko soap.
There's another addition called trooper.
So or is it the trooper bar trooper soap.
Yeah.
Nonetheless,
it's good.
Yeah.
This is good.
So yes,
it'll help you stay clean.
It'll make you stay clean.
Straight.
Yeah.
And hardcore kind of way.
Also Youtube,
if you're interested in the video version of this podcast,
Jocko telling us,
helping us,
advising us,
do advise.
I'm just over here saying my point of view I guess more than anything else.
Yeah.
And then,
and then echo makes videos I use super proud of and he's all hype about and he
thinks they're super cool.
So you can check us out too.
Yeah,
sure.
Yup.
There you go.
Nonetheless.
Yes.
Youtube Jocko,
podcasts,
youtube channels.
You have one six.
We do have our own youtube channel.
Yes.
You can sign up for a little announcements that come out.
Notifications.
I have that.
So whenever you post a video,
I get a notification.
Yeah.
And I go,
oh cool.
Echo post a video.
Should I watch it?
And then I go down and read the comments and someone says,
Akos lucky.
Yep.
So there's that comment in the world that,
and then psychological warfare,
you can get that if you need a little little assistance during a challenging
moment of weakness.
If you press play on your phone,
you can play a little track that will get you through that moment of weakness.
It's on iTunes,
Google play,
and pick your platforms of all kinds.
And if you want a visual representation to help keep you on the path.
Checkout flip side,
canvas.com where my brother Dakota Meyer is making art.
We put a on and he's putting into the art with layers.
That's what it is.
There you go.
You just,
you just go ahead and he's made the motto,
art with layers going to put some more of your kids' stuff up in there for your
kids rooms.
We're gonna put some more your kid things up there.
So be checking that out.
And if you have anything that you want to have on a canvas,
let Dakota Meyer,
no,
I hit him up on Twitter.
Tell him what's going on.
Tell him what you think he can make.
He can make it happen.
So there's that also on it,
on it.com so this is where you can get your kettle bells when you're,
when we are varying up.
Our workouts need more kettlebells.
You need more functional fitness type stuff.
That's where you get it.
Also,
like I mentioned before,
the the mineral slash electrolyte mix for the pre Jujitsu actually preworkout to
mega mix.
This is where you get it on at.com/jocko.
What if you,
I mean you don't,
you don't want to pre workout is it's called a pre workout.
Yeah.
It's like it has like a like dilators and caffeine and stuff in it.
It's mainly for like lifting or whatever.
Yeah,
you can mix the,
if you worked out,
don't do met cottons on this,
but if you're just lifting for like words or fee or whatever and then you like
preworkouts you mix that in the mega mix.
So you go preworkout discipline two scoops,
one scoop electrolytes from Onnit.
Um,
lemon juice,
water mix.
That report pack.
Who?
That's the mega mix right there for lifting for that shit to measure your biceps
report back.
Yes.
Yeah.
Your pump will be out of this world,
but before Jujitsu,
don't do the preworkout.
Don't do the caffeine before she did.
That's fine.
Anyway,
on it.com/chocolates where you get it,
got some books,
got some books coming out.
I got one book coming out called Warrior way of the warrior kid three where
there's a will.
Uh,
I think when this podcast out we
might even be live or close to it.
Yeah,
so way the warrior kid three order it immediately.
I just got the numbers prior to walking in here.
It's already selling like pretty awesome,
so appreciate everyone preordering it.
But if you want it,
order it now so I can print enough for you because the publishing company is
Jocko publishing.
Also.
We got way of the warrior kid one.
We got way the warrior kid to subtitle Mark's mission.
We the quarter,
whether where your kid,
one subtitle is from wimpy to war,
you're the navy seal way.
Teach your kid to be on the path.
And then if you've got a little bit younger kid,
get Mikey and the dragons miking the dragons will frame your child's mind to be
able to overcome fear for the rest of their lives.
Just a nice little thing to give them for the rest of your life.
You don't have to be afraid of anything.
Yes,
there you go.
There you go.
Child.
You're welcome.
Discipline equals freedom field manual.
That's how to get after it.
The audio of that is on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
another MP3,
extreme ownership and dichotomy of leadership.
Both those books I wrote with my brother Leif Babin and we take the experiences
we had in combat overseas,
the leadership lessons we learned and we pass them on to all of you.
Also,
we have actual in front,
which is our leadership consultancy and what we do is we solve problems through
leadership and if you want to have us come and work with your company and then
go to echelon front.com if you want to come to a live experience,
you can come to the monster.
May 23rd and 24th in Chicago sold out.
You won't be coming to that one.
September 19th and 20th in Denver.
Not sold out yet,
but it will end December 4th and fifth in Sydney,
Australia,
go to extreme ownership.com all of them have sold out.
All of them will sell out,
so get in the game early EMF online.
This is our,
if you can't make it to the muster but you want to get granular with your
leadership capabilities than go to f online.com and we will take you through
leadership courses that will pragmatically improve your leadership skills.
There's interactive decisions you have to make in those courses,
so check it out.
F online.com and then over watch if you're a business person and you are looking
for leaders,
which is what you need in your company.
You need leadership.
If you want leadership in your company,
we have a special operations and combat aviation veterans and
we are getting them placed into your company,
so go to e f Overwatch.
If you are looking for leaders in your company
and if you want to cruise hard more with us on the inner webs,
Twitter,
Instagram and on Facebook of course I medical Charles and Jack was at Jocko
Willink.
What are the three platforms?
Twitter,
Instagram,
and then Facebook.
Thank you.
I didn't,
I wasn't quite sure what you said.
Right.
And thanks to everyone out there that wears the cloth of our nation,
a military uniform.
Thank you for your sacrifice and thanks to your families as well,
who also sacrifice to keep the nation safe and thanks to police,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
EMT,
s dispatchers,
correctional officers,
border patrol,
secret service,
all first responders for what you do every day.
And thanks to your families as well for supporting you so that you all can
support us.
And everyone else out there,
remember that life goes by like a summer day
and you don't have time to get hung up on failures.
You don't have time to dwell on the past and you can't preserve the memories
perfectly.
So make sure you get out there every day and you make new memories by moving
forward
and getting after it.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.
Okay.